let's learn a little bit about the dot
product the dot product frankly out of
the two ways of multiplying vectors I
think it's the easier one so what is the
dot product do if one I'll give you the
definition and then I'll give you the
intuition so if I have two vectors to
vectors let's say vector a vector a dot
vector B that's how I draw my arrows
like a drop my arms like that that is
equal to the magnitude of vector a times
the magnitude of vector B times cosine
of the angle between them now where does
this come from this might seem a little
arbitrary but I think with a visual
explanation we'll make a little bit more
sense so let me draw arbitrarily these
two vectors so that is my vector a nice
big and fat vector it's good for showing
the point and let me draw a vector B
like that vector B and then let me draw
the cosine or let me at least draw the
angle between them this is Theta so
there's two ways of viewing this you
could view let me let me label them this
is vector a I'm trying to be color
consistent this is vector B so there's
two ways of viewing this this product
you could view it as vector a because
you can you know multiplication is
associative you could switch the order
so this could also be written as the
magnitude of vector a times cosine of
theta times cosine of theta times and
I'll do it in color appropriate times
vector B and this times isn't the dot
product I almost don't have to write it
there's just regular multiplication
because these are all scalar quantities
when you see the dot between vectors
you're talking about the vector dot
product so if we just rearrange this
expression this way what does it mean
what is a cosine of theta let me ask you
a question if I were to drop a right
angle right here perpendicular to B so
let's just drop right angle there cosine
of theta
sohcahtoa sohcahtoa so
cosine is equal to adjacent over
hypotenuse right well what's the
adjacent it's equal to this and the
hypotenuse is equal to the magnitude of
a right so let me rewrite that so cosine
of theta and all this applies to the a
vector cosine of theta of this angle is
equal to adjacent which is I don't know
what you could call this let's call this
the projection of a onto B right it's
like if you were to shine a light
perpendicular to B if you there was like
a light source here and adjust the light
show what was straight down it would be
the shadow of a on to B or you could
almost think of it is the part of a that
goes in the same direction of B so this
this projection they call it and at
least the way I get the intuition of
what a projection is I kind of view it
as a shadow if you had a if you had a
light source it came up perpendicular
what would be the shadow of that vector
onto this one so if you think about it
this shadow right here we could call
that the projection of a onto B or I
don't know let's just call it a sub B
and it's the magnitude of it right it's
how much of vector a goes on vector B
over a Jace that's the adjacent side
over the hypotenuse the hypotenuse is
just the magnitude of vector a right
there's just our basic calculus or
another way you could view it just
multiply both sides by the magnitude of
vector a you get the projection of a
onto B which is just a fancy way of
saying this side the part of a that goes
in the same direction as B is another
way to say is equal to just multiplying
both sides times the magnitude of a is
equal to the magnitude of a cosine of
theta which is exactly what we have up
here and the definition of the dot
product so another way of visualizing
the dot product is you can replace this
term with the magnitude of the
projection of a onto B which is just
this times the magnitude of B that's
interesting so what it
all the dot product of two vectors is it
says well let's just take one vector
let's figure out how much of that vector
what component of its magnitude goes in
the same direction as the other vector
and let's just multiply them and where
is that useful well think about it what
about work when we learn work in physics
work is Force Times distance but it's
not just the total force times the total
distance it's the force going in the
same direction as the distance so if I
have a you should review the physics
playlist if you're watching this within
the calculus playlist but let's say I
have a I don't know it's a 10 10 to
Newton 10 Newton object it's sitting on
ice so there's no friction we don't want
to worry about friction right now and
let's say I pull on it let's see my
force vector this is my force vector
let's say my force vector is my force
vector is I don't know 100 Newtons I'm
making numbers up 100 Newtons and let's
say the and that's a I pull it I slide
it to the right so my distance vector is
I don't know 10 meters my distance
vector is 10 meters parallel to the
ground and the angle between them is
equal to I don't know 60 degrees which
is the same thing as PI over 3 let's
stick in well say to do degrees it's a
little more intuitive it's 60 degrees so
my question this this distance right
here is 10 meters so my question is by
pulling on this you know rope or
whatever at this angle at the 60 degree
angle with a force of 100 Newtons and
pulling this block to the right for 10
meters how much work am i doing well
work is force times the distance but not
not just the total force the magnitude
of the force in the direction of the
distance so it actually turns so what's
the magnitude of the force in the
direction of the distance it would be
the component it would be the horizontal
component
of this forest vector right so it would
be 100 Newton's times the cosine of 60
degrees and would tell you how much of
that hundred Newton's goes to the right
or another way you could view it if this
is the force vector and that this down
here is the distance vector you could
say that the total work you performed is
equal to the force vector dot the
distance vector so time using the dot
product the dot product of the force in
the distance vector and we know that the
definition is the magnitude of the force
vector which is 100 Newton's times the
magnitude of the distance vector which
is 10 meters times the cosine of the
angle between them cosine of the angle
is 60 degrees so that's equal to 1000
Newton meters Newton meters times cosine
of 60 cosine of 60 is what its square
root of 3 over 2 right cosine of yep
square root of 3 over 2 if I remember
correctly so times the square root of 3
over 2 so the 2 this becomes 500 so it
becomes 500 square roots of 3 joules
whatever that is I know 700 something
I'm guessing maybe it's 800 something
I'm not quite sure but the important
thing to realize is that the the dot
product is useful it applies to work it
actually calculates what component of
what vector goes in the other direction
now you can interpret it the other way
you could say this is the magnitude of a
times B cosine of theta and that's
completely valid and what's B cosine of
theta well if you took B cosine of theta
and you could work this out as an
exercise for yourself that's the amount
of the magnitude of the B vector that's
going in the a direction so it doesn't
matter what order you go so contrary you
know and when you take the cross-product
it matters whether you do a cross B or B
cross a when you're doing the dot
product it doesn't matter one order so B
cosine theta would be the magnitude of
vector B that goes in the direction of a
so if you were to draw a perpendicular
line here drop a perpendicular B cosine
theta would be this vector
that would be B cosine theta the
magnitude of B cosine theta so you could
say how much of BEC vector B goes in the
same direction as a and then multiply
the two magnitudes or you could say how
much of vector a goes in the same
direction as vector B and then multiply
the two magnitudes and now this is I
think a good time to just make sure you
understand the difference between the
dot product and the cross product the
dot product ends up with just a number
you multiply two vectors and all you
have is a number you don't have it you
end up with just a scalar quantity and
why is that interesting well it tells
you it just it tells you how much do
these do these you can almost say these
vectors reinforce each other because
it's you're taking their magnitudes the
parts of their magnitudes that go in the
same direction and multiplying them the
cross product is actually almost the
opposite you're taking the orthogonal
components right the difference was this
was a sine of theta and I don't want to
mess you up this picture too much but
you should review the cross product
videos and I'll do another video where I
actually compare and contrast them but
the cross product is you're saying let's
multiply the magnitudes of the vectors
that are perpendicular to each other
that aren't going in the same direction
that are actually orthogonal to each
other and then you have to pick a
direction since you're not saying well
the same direction that you know they're
both going in here actually so you're
picking the direction that's orthogonal
to both vectors and then that's why the
or the the orientation matters you have
to take the right-hand rule because
there's actually two vectors that go
that are perpendicular to any other two
vectors in three dimensions anyway I'm
all out of time I'll continue this
hopefully not too confusing discussion
in the next video I'll compare and
contrast the cross product and the dot
product see in the next video